as we mentioned at the top of the hour
chicago mayor lori lightfoot making a
major announcement in the city's battle
to get
children back in the classroom
we are here to announce the very good
news
that our children will be returning to
in-person learning
this week chicago just one example of
the battle between schools and teachers
unions over how
and when to get kids back to the
classroom for more let's bring in our
panel former aide to democratic senator
chuck schumer and host of the aggressive
progressive podcast
chris hahn and fox news contributor and
assistant editor of the wall street
journal's editorial page james freeman
gentlemen welcome good to be here thanks
great to be here mike
i want to play this clip from cdc
director dr rochelle walensky
i also want to be clear that there is
increasing
data to suggest that schools can safely
reopen
and that that safe reopening does not
suggest that teachers need to be
vaccinated in order to reopen safely
vaccination of teachers
is not a prerequisite for safe reopening
of schools
chris did she go off script or was she
just being honest
she's being honest in the biden
administration they don't have scripts
like they did in the previous
administration so
and i think she's 100 right our first
priority as a nation should be getting
our kids back to school here in new york
most districts are back to school and
have been back
since september i understand that there
are concerns in some urban areas
about being able to properly social
distance in these classrooms and i think
what mayor lifeport did in chicago
was work with the union to come to an
acceptable solution to get kids back in
the classroom
that should be being done across the
country in every city in every school
district because kids
should be in the classroom and they
should be learning it's very important
to their development to be fair though
jen saki came out a couple hours later
and said that dr wolenski was giving her
personal view and that wasn't
the official cdc guidelines james your
thoughts
yeah the president unfortunately has
been saying that
some schools shouldn't have to reopen
for months uh
really they never should have closed uh
the doctor willenski there was uh
expressing what the science tells us in
this country and in countries all over
the world
schools were never the super spreader
events
some people feared they would be the
kids obviously are at very little risk
and most of the staff are at very little
risk
most teachers not in the high risk
category these schools should be open
and every day they're not we're robbing
these kids
of the skills the learning they need to
earn in the future so we are basically
stealing from their future earnings
every day that we have them out of class
chris a tentative deal in chicago
announced by the mayor
uh are you hopeful that this is the
start of a trend of
uh some of these big districts getting
children back in the classroom
absolutely and i think it takes
leadership on the part of whether it be
a mayor or governor
or a school board president to work with
their teachers and their teachers unions
to come to accommodations to get kids
back in the classrooms i think it is
it's not something that is a political
issue unions have the right to negotiate
and feel safe
and they should be able to do that but
the leaders of those districts on the
other side
should be able to work with them and
work out a deal just like mayor
lightfoot did in chicago and
congratulations to her
and let's hope that spreads across this
nation because the schools that are open
those kids are getting a benefit
that are really to the detriment of kids
who are not in classrooms and i think
it's very important that we have
equality in education across this
country james i want to get you to weigh
in on the
story we confirmed from the washington
post basically saying that the body
administration
is going to reduce arrests reduce
deportations kind of take the teeth
out of ice your thoughts on that
well we'll see i mean i i think people
might have gotten confused watching
those
debates last year thinking that the the
difference in practice and policy
uh between the uh biden and uh trump
administrator is
but uh i i think he's uh the president
now i think he's going to find
that you do have to enforce a border or
you
invite people to attempt to cross who
are not coming in
legally now that having been said i
would hope that
the president will now seek the deal
that nancy pelosi
never really wanted to try with donald
trump is to get border enforcement but
also more
legal immigration for people who want to
come here and work and be productive
citizens
gentlemen we have to leave it there
thanks so much for your time thanks